So today we're going to be reviewing
wulong Fallen Dynasty it's pretty much
the next souls-like experience and I
actually think we're getting to the
point where it's unfair to these
developers like team ninja to constantly
refer their games to from softwares type
of genre that you know it was all
fairness they did kind of Spawn this
genre now look am I saying they made it
from scratch or anything like that no
but I would say it's fair to say that
from software took this type of gameplay
and then made it mainstream first off I
want to thank koe Tecmo and Xbox for
providing us with this review code for
the purposes of reviewing the game you
know they've been very good to us they
make sure we get that content to you
guys because that's all that matters man
tell find games that might Vibe with you
and without any further Ado here is my
review on wulong Fallen Dynasty for the
Xbox series X let's get it
[Music]
all right
what's going on you guys Lord added here
coming at you with another Lord's review
today we're going to be reviewing wulong
Fallen Dynasty for the Xbox series X
published by koe Tecmo and developed by
team ninja you guys know the Neo
franchise that's that's the developers
that made this game first off clearly
this is a from software type of game you
know that genre that they kind of Spun
into their own little thing now
obviously they originate this genre but
I would say they mainstream this genre
now let's go ahead and give context
behind me and type of souls like games
in general for those of you that's been
on this channel for a while you know
that I am a huge fan of from software
types of games you've got souls-like
experience I like the Elden Rings The
Dark Souls the Demon Souls I like the
bloodborne's I actually really like Neo
and so when I saw wulong Dynasty show up
I was like you know this is something
that I would definitely try out you know
like I said shout out to them for
sending me the review code and we really
broke down this game you know first
thing I really want to talk about is the
story of oolong Dynasty now there's been
a lot of Inspirations on a lot of
different lures and backgrounds this was
mainly sticking around Chinese lore you
know the Dynasty Warrior games I'm sure
a lot of you really messed with those
games when you was younger you're gonna
notice a lot of those characters are in
this game so that's one thing that
automatically out the gate when it comes
to the story of wulong that jumped out
at me is I have seen the characters in
this game and other forms of media and
I've seen them in other games and I feel
like when you gravitate towards
especially something as popular as
Dynasty Wars that still has a franchise
to this day let's be real that game is
still going on and the good thing that
team ninja has done here is they've took
that success that they have made in the
past with something like Dynasty
Warriors they took those characters and
they put them in a new format where
people that play those games will see
these characters and they'll be drawn to
them and it's a different type of
gameplay you can actually get those
people and you can get the souls like
fans as well and I really hats off to
them when it comes to stuff like that
pretty much when it comes to the story
of this game it's nothing extremely
special but I it is enough to keep you
interested in the story to a point
pretty much what's going on is there's
these things called the elixirs that's
going on in the world and pretty much if
people drink these elixirs stuff really
bad happens and they're trying to find
the actual Source behind who is doing
these elixirs who is Distributing them
that is the gist of the story now
obviously that is a very Cliff note
version of it I don't want to really
ruin anything I don't really want to
name any characters but there's a lot
that goes into this I will say it's
engaging enough to want you to know
what's gonna happen next and want you to
see certain characters again but I
wouldn't really say that the narrative
was explained in a very good way a good
comparison I would give you is something
like Sakura Shadow dies twice now I
thought that narrative was actually told
a little bit better in this game but I
don't think that it was a huge
difference I think if you like the story
in sakro and I like the story in secro I
think you would get an engaging story in
this it is good for the time that we're
in now but it's nothing not like a Last
of Us or God of War clearly this game
was revolved around the gameplay the
gameplay mechanics and I'm not saying
that they shoehorned the story in there
by any means but I do know that like
look they're like we're gonna give you
an engaging story but we really want to
build on these foundations of the
gameplay to make you really enjoy
playing the story and I think that is
what team ninja was going for here and I
think they did a pretty decent job at it
now let's talk about the art of this
game the art style and the performance
overall in general now I felt like the
art style in this game was good there's
a lot of dark moments it's a very dark
Grimmy looking game I felt like the
elements was done very well there's a
lot of elements attacks here the special
effects was done well the animations was
done well it's a very good looking game
now like I said it's nothing I can do
but but I do think when you look at this
game you're like yo I really like the
overall Aesthetics of the game it's very
pleasing uh you know there's a lot of
different variety of fields in here
there's snow there's a lot of fire maps
on here I felt like the bosses were done
well the art style was done well you
know just over all the Aesthetics of woo
long Fallen Dynasty and I have to get my
hats off to them because I feel like
with these games it's either one or the
other you know you get good animations
but bad boss design good artwork but bad
Direction where they go with the art and
I think this one it's a solid experience
of everything and it's good good choices
man good choices team ninja you're
turning out to be up there with from
software I'm not gonna go out there and
say you want salt from software levels
yet but you know I think you're getting
closer and closer to that Divine source
of from software now let's talk about
the performance this is the first time
I'm really gonna talk down on this game
I did play this on the Xbox series X and
I did have a lot of issues when it turns
to stuttering there was a couple times
at the end of the game where the game
just full-blown crashed it was multiple
times now I will say that it didn't
bother me much and I want to go out
right now and say that you know before
you pick this game up go let look look
and see about some patch notes see if
they fixed stuttering see if they fit
some of the crashes that's happening in
the game now it's not gonna happen to
everybody I did feel like it mainly
happened when a lot of things was going
on the field when there's a lot of fire
elements going on there's some poison
some ice there's a lot of Sword clashing
going on I don't know if the reasons
that these are happening but I wanted
you guys to be very transparent on that
is there is some performance issues with
this game I've been seeing on Twitter
there's issues with you know frame rates
on on PC in general but what I want to
say is terms of the Xbox series X for
the most part I would say about 85 90 of
the time the game runs very well but
then there'll be just random pauses for
for no reason like straight up pausing
the game and you have to wait to either
the game crashes or it resumes playing
and that was annoying to a point now
it's like I said it wasn't to the point
where I just dropped it because I have
dropped games in the past that did not
run well but it was enough to where I
want to let you guys know that I did
have performance issues with the Xbox
series X for that matter now let's talk
about something that you guys know I
flourished when it comes to these style
games these Souls likes games and that
is just the gameplay overall I felt like
the gameplay to this compared to their
previous work something like Neo is on a
completely different level look I like
Neo but I did feel like it was too
floaty now this game isn't as floaty but
I feel like it's a better mixture than
it was with Neo one thing I want to
bring up about team ninja games is
please stop with the a complete
abundance of weapons you have no idea
how what's what I'm looking for how
overwhelmed I am when I'm looking
through the menus and the weapons and
the armor and the accessories and
there's literally two to three to four
to even sometimes five to ten seconds of
scrolling down when it comes to
equipment when it comes to weapons and
when it comes to just overall
accessories I'm like look I get it I
understand they want to give you options
they want to make you feel like you have
the ability to play this game however
you want and to a point I respect that
but when you look at games like
bloodborne you look at a lot of the from
software games Elden ring even know that
there's more options in some of these
games to others they never overwhelm you
with this much gear sometimes I'm
looking at this stuff and I understand
that I can make amazing builds but when
I look at the insane amount of equipment
just makes me not want to even you know
test around try it you know at least
they give you in the blacksmith
opportunity they let you take certain of
the perks out and maybe put them in with
other things but but you know what's
funny is the fact that I didn't even
really mess with this stuff because I
was just always overwhelmed every time I
looked at it I'm sitting there scrolling
down you know they do give you some
options into what you can do with it
they let you make money they let you
gave items you can upgrade all the stuff
you have in the game and the good thing
is they give you a transmog system with
anything in the game so if you want your
character to look like a certain other
part of gear that you have but you don't
want the stats that come with it or the
the Aesthetics that come with it they
give you the option to change it I like
that I think every game needs to do that
because especially with these games that
involve you know all this ancient armor
this heavy armor this type of Samurai
armor because a lot of these games when
you look at it it's about Aesthetics
about how you want your character to
look and there's nothing more irritating
and frustrating to see a style that you
really Vibe with and you want to look
like but the stats are garbage but you
see this other armor that you hate the
way it looks but this stats are way
better and the game pretty much forces
you to look the way you don't want to
look because of stats and what I will
say to team ninjas Bravo for giving the
players and The Gamers the option to
pretty much look however you want to
look I didn't know to the extent can you
look like this I don't know if you can
take smaller armor and you know transmog
it to bigger armor I'm assuming they
want you to stay in the same weight loss
so pretty much there's three weights in
this game there's one bar two bar and
three bars depending on what your stats
are and how much you can you know have
equipment I'm assuming that you can
change out any one star or one bar
equipment to look like any other one bar
equipment it looked like the ones that
you can transform is something that you
find on the field or maybe it was the
characters you have like I said I didn't
really mess around with the transmog
system too much I found what looked good
to me and that's pretty much where I
kept it on but I want you guys to know
that there is options if you want to
look like different types of armor that
you may or may not have I another cool
things I have to give to team ninjas how
they did the boss design in this system
now all of them was definitely some
rinse and repeat you know some of them
felt a little bit identical to others
now I wouldn't say that they never
actually took something that you fought
in the past and made it a boss in the
present now they did do that on certain
challenges but it wasn't like one of the
main bosses what I will say is towards
the beginning of the game some of the
things you fight or turn into regular
enemies and you see that practice pretty
much done in any game so I don't want to
really you know punish them for that I
feel like that is a standard practice
and I think a lot of people accept that
kind of stuff because it's kind of like
tutorial bosses where these are just
bigger mini bosses at the end of the day
and there's a lot of them I do feel like
they do repeat those particular bosses
once they're made into regular ads you
will see them a lot they don't have the
traditional boss meter but they have a
good sizable amount of Health that you
have to go through and you do fight them
quite a bit one thing I will say when it
comes to the bosses is there's a
particular boss in this game that for
the first time in a long time fighting
these type of bosses in any of these
Souls like games I was generally might
have gave up now I still went ahead you
know I bucked down I hit a wall and I
was like there's no other way I can do
to come into this fight as a better
opportunity to beat this individual imma
just have to hunker down and be good I'm
gonna have to make sure I get all my
parries I'll have to make sure I land
all of my attacks all my counter attacks
I'm not the Dodge correctly and those
are the type of fights that I really
enjoy now there was one or two of these
in the game and I think that the one in
particular I'm talking about was that
one that I really enjoyed because I felt
like it was a good fight you know God
you know what I'm talking about you know
those fights that you feel frustrated
not in a good way this particular fight
now I'm not gonna say I'm sure people in
the comment section will know who I'm
talking about it was a good fight and a
less frustrating way okay Charles
frustrated I kept dying but I knew it
wasn't them I knew it wasn't the game
working against me it was me having to
get better to fight that enemy in a
better way and I think a lot of bosses
and a lot of these type of games is more
one way than the other it's more the
latter but I will say there's a couple
good fights in here those one-on-one
fights that everyone really enjoys that
is in this game and I think you guys
will really like the boss fight
mechanics and the boss fights in general
in wulong Dynasty now wulong definitely
has its issues the issues that I had in
the game was a couple different factors
let's go over some of these issues you
know let's let everyone grab a chair sit
around attic let's talk about it like I
said the biggest issue is the too many
weapons we don't need really to go into
that too much because we already went
into that I don't like the stealth
system in here now there is a stealth
system but it's not that good it's
pretty much you know depending on how
you get the water tribute up which you
know pretty much the way you level up is
there's five tiles you know earth water
not going to go into all of it you guys
know how the system works when you level
up stuff up and when you level these
things up at levels multiple of those
attributes up with it well when you
level the water attribute up you level
up your overall stealth mechanics in the
game so pretty much the higher that is
the better you're going to be at
stealthing and I didn't like that system
now I don't mind leveling up in a
tribute to have a better stealth
mechanic but the problem with Wu long in
terms of stealth is there's no Crouch
button there's no hunker down button so
it's pretty much you have to walk as
slow as you can without letting them
turn around because keep in mind a lot
of the stuff mechanics in this game is
going to be dealing with a walking enemy
enemies that are going in a line or a
certain patrolling a certain area and
there's nothing more frustrating than
not being able to walk at a certain
speed because you don't want to show who
they are you don't want them hearing you
and when you get close to them you might
have to actually go a little bit faster
than you would have normally liked I'll
like when you have an actual stealth
button in the game look at secro when
you can actually Crouch I like being
able to hit that button and going the
exact fastest speed I can go without
being seen and I don't know why wulong
does not have this system it's very
frustrating how many times in this game
I came up right on someone right when
I'm about to do a stealth attack because
it pretty much signals like there's a
red line or a red circle on their back
and right when I'm about to press it
they they turn around or I go a little
bit more fast than I should have went
and they see sure maybe that's I need to
learn it better but I don't think that's
what it is put a stealth system in the
game if you're going to put mechanics
leading towards a stealth system you
gotta have a button dedicated to stealth
and I don't like the fact that wulong
dynasty did not have one it was by far
the most infuriating thing about this
game another thing I didn't like is the
fortify morality system in the game so
let's talk about what a morality system
is in wulong Dynasty when you defeated
and to me you get a percentage onto a
bar that goes up from 1 to 25 and pretty
much what that is is the difference
between
and your opponent if it's up to five or
lower than five so let's say I'm a
morality system of 20 and my enemy is 15
or maybe 25 I don't think there's any
enemies that is 25. there is a
significant advantage to the person with
the higher morality system now what a
fortify system is is there's these flags
that are out that are through the map
and at first I thought they were like a
fast travel system but not really now
when you put them down you get a certain
point onto your fortify system and when
you die your morality comes back to what
your fortify system is so let's say you
diet 25 and you put a certain amount of
flags down where you're fortification
your fortify system number is let's say
15. you'll come back as a level 15 in
Morality because your fortify number was
15. now I'm not going to say this was
like a horrible system I just feel like
that with the leveling system with the
weapon system I just feel like it was
too much I feel like you didn't need all
this now I think it's far is like
casualizing the franchise without really
hurting the hardcore aspect this
actually works out a little bit better
because you'll actually not be attacked
so much from just basic enemies because
when you're fortified let's say you're
15 and fortified when you come back you
keep coming back as a 15 20 because 20
is the max that you can get from four to
five and if you keep killing enemies
you'll get that extra five for a total
of 25 morality most bosses are 20 you
know in in game bosses they're they're
about 20. so you come in there doing
more damage alrighty so that's a
mechanic that you can use to your
advantage to actually do damage to it
now I'm not going to say it was a bad
thing I'm a little in the middle you
know at the beginning I was completely I
didn't like it but after playing the
game enough and realizing the system
enough I've realized that this is
something that can help people not rage
as much because they're not getting one
shot by regular ads because they have a
high fortify system if they're at the
end of that level and can go back and
grind but at the same time when you're
coming into it and you have to deal with
all of these systems it gets very
overloading and very frustrating to say
the least now Wu long Dynasty is
definitely one of those games that I
would recommend to you guys I really
enjoyed this game the boss system was
good the level up system was good I feel
like there's some things they could have
did a little bit differently like you
know like I said the weapon system you
know maybe the fortifying morality
system could have went to a degree I'm
not going to really argue with them too
much on that I think that is definitely
good for some people not good for others
and I feel like the sound design is
amazing the art style is good this is
just a solid game now you can make the
argument that a game like this maybe if
they really go above and beyond with a
sequel or take the foundation of this
game and really build on it they can
potentially make games that are on the
level of from software the Dark Souls
the Elden ring I don't think they're
there yet but I do think that one could
argue that team ninja is probably the
only company that's even making games
even close to what from software makes
in this type of souls genre what people
call it that's why I recommend it I
think this is easily worth the money
that goes into keep in mind it's in Game
Pass so you can always go and if you
subscribe to Game Pass just go download
it try it out I don't think this is a
good entry for new Souls type games now
obviously the the fortify morality
system can make it a little bit easier
to jump in on I think there is some
aspects of this that if you don't like
it you like games like Dynasty Warriors
maybe this is a little bit open to you
there's a lot of good characters that if
you played those games that you'll
really enjoy here but as far as that
typically the only people are going to
really really love this game is Souls
like people I do hope they fix those
performance issues like I said
definitely go check the patch notes and
make sure that these were fixed before
you go out and invest into something
like this and and until next time this
is Lord addict and this is my review on
wulong Dynasty for the Xbox series X and
if you guys enjoyed this review
definitely hit that subscribe button you
can actually like the video that really
helps the Channel we do a podcast every
Sunday at 1pm known as the iron Lords
podcast I'm a panelist member on there
it's the channel that you're currently
watching this review on and like I said
I hope you guys have a good day and
until the next review this is Lord
addict I'm out of here peace